معركه التصريحات والاجراءات المضاده
تتواصل بين الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
والحزب الجمهوري قبيل موعد الانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله التي ستشكل حدا فاصلا في
مستقبل بايدن السياسي رفع سقف الدين العام
يضم الى قائمه طويله من اسباب الصراع
الحاصل بين الرئيس الامريكي والجمهوريين
في مجلس النواب والذي سيحمل معه تداعيات
صعبه سترهق كاهل الاداره الامريكيه
الحاليه مع تحوله لاداه سياسيه تعزز
الانقسامات الايديولوجيه بين الحزبين
وتساهم بالدرجه الاولى في زعزعه مكانه
بايدن الذي لم يتمكن لحد الان من مواجهه
الازمات المتتاليه التي تمر بها البلاد
ابرزها جائحه كورونا وفق مراقبين بايدن
اليوم امام مازق سياسي معقد وضروره ايجاد
حل يرضي جميع الاطراف هو الحل الوحيد
لتدارك الموقف وكسب رهان التاييد الشعبي
خصوصا وان شعبيته تراجعت في الفتره
الاخيره غير ان هذا الحل مرتبط بالطرق
التي سيتم اعتمادها للتخفيف من الانفاق
ورفع سقف الدين طرق يتم بموجبها قبول
البيت الابيض بوضع حدود للانفاق الفيدرالي
وفرض قيود على الاعانات الاجتماعيه وهو ما
سيؤثر في سياق المتصل على حجم الانفاق
العسكري الامريكي وايضا تاثر العلاقات
الامريكيه الصينيه التي تعتبر فيها في كين
اكبر دائن التشققات في هذه العلاقه ستتعمق
في حال التوقف عن سداد الديون الاميركيه
وستدفع الصين الى تعزيز موقعها في مجموعه
البريكس فضروره تمرير مشروع قانون يحظى
بتاييد الحزبين بات امرا ملحن وفق تصريحات
زعيم الاغلبيه المطلقه في مجلس الشيوخ
لتجنب خسائر فادحه ستواجهها اسواق المال
الامريكيه
والعالميه
مزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات